is there a wild card that nobody's
expecting
that would um advance self-driving
quicker because most people seem to be
thinking that
you know the the steering wheel comes
out in year 10 and
you know to your point like on highways
we might be able to get a little bit of
our time back you know
in you know whatever it is 2022 2028
somewhere in that timeframe
we'll be able to take our eyes off the
road for a small amount of time or
periods of time
but is there any technology that could
be game changing either
in chip technology or sensor technology
that's in the work that people are
looking at going well if that goes right
boy that could be a game changer are
there any game changers you can think of
so the interesting sensor technology i'm
looking at
and no one quite builds it um i've seen
presentations but they all say 18 months
away which is like never
yeah that's the standard technologies
yeah yeah and that is
um 5g and it's not
and not using it for a data transport
one of the things that 5g
has is it has a beam forming radar in it
ah
5g at its high frequencies operates at
the same frequencies as radar yeah but
instead of just being a single pulse
that you send out in the scene
you can actually scan the scene by
controlling the direction of the beam
wow and so what what's interesting to me
about that is first you could make a
high-resolution
radar return but based on solid-state
devices that are in every single phone
so you get high quality high quality
you know that will drive the power down
drive the cost down so you have those
forces
so there's something there in the in
you're gonna have one side of it the 5g
people
you know driving the costs on the
intended design driving cost on the dsps
or however you process the signals
yeah and that would be very interesting
for us as
a really call it unintelligent collision
avoider right
in that it doesn't have to understand
anything all it has to do
is say i want to avoid frontal
collisions and you could build a very
very simple system that would prevent
all forward collisions i think that
would be
a very interesting advance why doesn't
that exist as a
standard safety technology that
every car is required to have you know
under 35 miles an hour
slam on the brakes if you're gonna hit
something within five feet of your
period
like shouldn't that be much easier than
self-driving to create
as a you know airbag type you know
stepping stone along the way and just
get rid of
every single fender bender and then
retrofit every
old car like that could be a 300 product
for you that insurance companies would
pay for and say you know what no more
fender benders
technology in the auto industry evolved
very slowly i think that's what it comes
down to it's like
it already has to be proven and some of
that is because when you
when you build something into a car as
opposed to adding it on
cars have like a 20-year lifetime right
and so
that's often why technology in the auto
industry tends to lag the consumer
industry by five to seven years
because it takes a bunch of extra time
to prove that some piece of electronics
is going to last 20 years into the
future
and so i i think it it's something that
they'll probably
it'll yeah it probably will seem to be
intimate
yeah that'd be the ultimate aftermarket
thing just no fender benders
you put this device like a you know
those in-depth those in
grille radar detectors you can get
aftermarket like an in-grill device that
just slams on the brakes
if there's something right in front of
you just solve that one acute problem
that's got to be
half of all accidents are tiny 35 mile
an hour or less
fender benders right yeah